okay so the hawkeye finale is finally
here and the episode is packed with
easter eggs hidden details and some big
reveals it answers some major questions
but also sets things up for the future
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking the entry down and going
over everything you need to know about
it i just want to get straight into it
but as always there will be heavy
spoilers so if you haven't checked it
out then check out now also please drop
a thumbs up if you've enjoyed any of the
videos we've done over the past five
weeks and thank you as always for
rocking with your boy without the way
i'm your uncle kevin spoilers now let's
get into hawkeye okay so last episode we
found out that elena was snap and
because of this she never got to say
goodbye to her sister as she believed
that clint was somewhat responsible for
natasha's death she had a sit down with
kate bishop and said that if she didn't
stay out her way that she'd beat that
bishop oh kevin spoilers you are so
funny that's hilarious that one is the
funniest
now elena ended up trying to track down
who hired her and this led her to not
only eleanor but also the big guy in
charge she sent a picture of the pair
together to kate and that should be a
fully caught up now the episode is
called so this is christmas and note of
the song happy christmas war is over by
john lennon this very much sums up the
entry and how things end up going to war
but then it ends up being over now we
open on the other side of elena's
photograph from last week and find out
that kate's dad was actually deeply
indebted to the kingpin this was
somewhat mirrored and echo's father who
we learned in episode 3 didn't have
enough money to pay for her to go to a
specialist school because he was in over
his head this is clearly why he had him
killed and he does set up the rivalry
between the kingpin and echo now they
have changed things up slightly from how
they were in the daredevil netflix
series as in those kingpin didn't have a
cane this character tray actually pulls
directly from the comics as the villain
often carried one with him so brings
things slightly more in line with that
now we still don't know if the mcu is
going to class the netflix shows as
canon or if the characters are going to
be variants of them as there's a lot of
history to twist the mcu to fit nor did
i've 2d been to spoilers for spider-man
now i home either but there was also a
character from the show that popped up
in that so it's gonna be interesting to
see how they're integrated into stuff
honestly i'm just happy the kingpin is
back and i love this little cane edition
now eleanor wants to get out the game
and we learned that many of our
suspicions were indeed true she killed
armand and also made it so that jack
took the fall for sloan limited
realizing that kate is getting too close
to the truth she decides to break their
deal and we learn that she has blackmail
material on the kingpin after keeping
records of their transactions this is
somewhat similar to the allen season one
of daredevil who tried to pull the same
trick on kingpin in order to stop him
from retaliating for attempting to kill
vanessa kingpin still took him out so it
doesn't bode too well for eleanor and
yeah the guy has no chill now kate is
shocked to see this conversation all
play out and hanging up in the room we
can also catch a dragons of despair
poster giving a nod to the role-playing
game clint says that this is his mess
and that he's not going anywhere until
it's all finished across town we go back
to the kingpin having a hawaiian
christmas and we should just all let the
man celebrate the holidays maya comes to
him which is when he apparently learns
about what's been happening this was of
course all kept from him but clearly
cause he filled him in even though both
karzian echo promised to keep things a
secret it starts to hint towards where
causey's real loyalties lie and come the
end of the episode that leads to his
demise he tells her exactly what he
wants to hear well well signs it and i
actually have a theory that though cause
he translates it kingpin understands her
in daredevil season 1 when talking to
madame gao they initially used a
translator but we learned that this was
actually just the kingpin pretending he
didn't understand to see if gao would
let anything slip after the death of his
father kingpin moved to asia and learned
several languages and i believe that
he's pretending not to be able to sign
to her to see what she's really saying
and if cause he will say something
different he knows how to say i love you
and i think that come her solo show we
may learn that he understood her the
whole time he clearly doesn't believe
maya is still loyal and angered at the
ronin eleanor and echo he decides to
give everyone a reminder that the city
belongs to him back on the subway we
then watch somewhat of a scene that
mirrors the one from the third episode
whereas that was clint stressing about
his family now it's kate they even had a
family therapy poster up in that scene
during the third episode so i love how
it's reflected here with kate who's now
dealing with her nasty mother now kate
and clint end up assembling an arsenal
of trick arrows and not only does this
call back to earlier in the season but
it also pulls directly from the cherry
issue in the comic run there were
several of them including sonic ones
putty ones net ones and a boomerang one
which was how the pair actually managed
to beat the tracksuit mafia they stock
up on a lot of them here and it makes
for an awesome finale in which they add
a couple more strings to their bow in
order to take the bad guys down i
absolutely love diy scenes like this and
we also get some stock industry ones
that carry across the corporation's logo
this is popped up in several marvel
properties in a missile shape like what
we have here and it's nice watching them
at least somewhat reference that now
this scene also carries with it kate
finally telling clint about her
childhood and why he means so much to
her throughout the show he's very much
wrestled with the position that people
have put him in as he doesn't think that
he's a hero in his eyes he very much let
nat take the fall for the soul stone and
he was simply someone who went along and
collected it he said that he's not a
role model but this moment very much
shows that he is and even if he doesn't
have superpowers he can still stand
shoulder to shoulder with the best of
them which shows that humanity has
potential it really means a lot to kate
and he watches the truster bro vans move
out bro is of course something that the
tracksuit mafia say all the time so this
company front was poking fun at their
catchphrase i think we can now confirm
as well that the fat man order repair
was poking fun at the kingpin 2 and it
all comes to a head at the rockefeller
plaza now this scene actually pulls
somewhat from the comics though they
have changed things up quite a lot
originally in the source material a tape
that apparently showed clint killing a
dictator was sold at a black market
auction held by madame mask this
somewhat paralleled the ronin suit and
sword auction that happened in the first
entry but the skyscraper itself was
where it took place set in the map
fraction run a one point clint ended up
jumping out of the skyscraper and there
was a big shoot up inside of it which
this episode is clearly giving nods to
the rockefeller center is where the
final scene of spider-man noah home
takes place and though it happened in
the snow unfortunately he doesn't show
up for this guy was probably just
looking out of his window letting it
happen thinking sod that they'll not
remember me anyway now inside they try
to track down eleanor and we learn that
the larpers have infiltrated the night
dressed as staff gave me a lot of fight
club vibes and we also learned that jack
was bailed out by little almonds father
though we don't learn who this is it
could also be another almond now in the
comics jack's father armin instilled in
him the idea to become the superhero the
swordsman he told him of his ancestor
the crimson cavalier and jack ended up
taking on the mantle the swordsman
becoming an anti-hero in the comics we
then see carsi sitting waiting with a
sniper rifle and elena checks in looking
like steve harvey this scene was so
great and hearing the nutcracker song in
the background perfectly sets the tone
kay confronts her mother with the video
of the kingpin and she's clearly very
remorseful of how things have turned out
it puts her in a lot of danger and she
was clearly just trying to protect kate
like she promised to at her father's
funeral because he started his attack i
love how clint quickly grabs a drinks
tray to use it as a shield man was
clearly taking notes from cap and it
happens so quick you might miss how
slick sun is with it now kate and elena
have a great little exchange and i love
how the ladder is constantly trying to
stop kate from messing up her plan it
really sets up the rivalry between them
that will no doubt last for the next
couple of years now you might notice
that elena also has blue eyelashes which
could be a nod to how she's working
alongside val who had the same colour
blue in her hair during falcon in the
winter soldier elena ends up pulling her
dress off to reveal her hawkeye costume
underneath and when kate presses all the
buttons on the elevator they end up
running through the building such a nice
little exchange and yeah it is annoying
when people do that we watch as they
move through the offices and one
continuous shot and kate ends up using
bowlers which are actually one of her
signature weapons in the comics i wish
elena would stop making me like her too
as i just want her to stop killing clint
but she won't give up now this big
action scene does change things up quite
a lot from the finale of the comic book
run in that clint ended up taking over
an apartment block from the mafia after
they tried to charge the tenant's triple
rent in order to extort them throughout
the book they had several run-ins with
him and they ended up hiring causey to
kill him but this failed in the end the
mafia stormed the apartment block and we
got a sort of home alone two showdown in
which clint and kate used a lot of trick
arrows to take them out one by one they
were joined by the other tenants and it
was a brilliant way to wrap up the run
though i do think that this action scene
here also works really well for a final
place for things to go down the
rockefeller center is probably the first
thing that people think of when they
think of new york at christmas and it's
a brilliant setting to have the showdown
at at the end of the book clint had cozy
in the corner but he had a trick up his
sleeve however clint managed to defeat
him by flicking a toothpick in his eye
in order to take away his sight cause he
was actually the one who made clint
death as he stabbed him in the ears with
some of his arrows so it was sort of
like poetry there you're right terrible
catchphrase that i'm a bit good i
brought back now we see how easy that
elena descends from the window and in
comparison how difficult it is for kate
to look cool now though she's getting
called a mary sue by the people that
call every female character or mary sue
i have really liked the way they've
handled her and as far as origin stories
go this has slowly built her up over
time showing both her strengths and
weaknesses very very well they also have
a moment where she steps on a giant
keyboard and shout out simone berman on
twitter for pointing out that this is a
call back to big outside the mafia
attack and we learn from the member that
was gonna go to the imagine dragons
concert and he ended up going to a
maroon 5-1 instead kate is saved by jack
who shows how adept he is i think that
going forward with eleanor getting
jailed at the end of the episode that he
might actually become somewhat of a
mentor to her he could clearly best her
with a sword so i think that would be a
brilliant direction to take things as
she learns more he does end up joining
the larpers come the end so they might
not make him fully go into the swordsman
but i think having him remaining hates
life would be a really good way to go he
does a quite similar to her father and
with her losing her mother it would be a
nice continuation of the character in my
opinion now inside the building causey
and clint come face to face with clint
taking your boy down chased by the rest
of the mafia down a corridor i kind of
got a lot of vibes of the ending of
endgame from this but obviously these
guys don't want to rip his head off
clint jumps out the window and ends up
landing in a tree which is where he
comes across an owl this sort of becomes
like the rat and end game and the
larpers decide to mount up across town
though maya packs a bag she ends up
leaving to go and confront quasi who is
pictured along with her and her father
kate gets clean out of the tree by
bringing it down with an acid arrow and
this ends up putting clint on ice like
captain america now finally he takes off
his shirt to reveal his hawkeye costume
and this looks very similar to how it
was in the map fraction run with a logo
on the front in the ice rink the pair
make their final stand and using magna
arrows they disarm the mafia the trick
arrows really brought a smile to my face
and watching the spindles one the ice
one that like like freezes that guy's
entire leg and just all of them they
work really well to show why hawkeye can
mess people up pretty easily watching
kate and clint work together as a team
is great and we get a hero shot much
like the avengers one to cement they
made it made it a bloody great show now
lastly kate uses a pin arrow to shrink
down the truster bro truck and although
it was pretty messed up that they got
carried away by an owl they're not going
to be able to return to normal size and
are probably gonna end up being eaten by
an owl which isn't very cool also if you
watch this scene with subtitles on it
says noise of children screaming now
kazi arrives and though clint uses a
triple arrow he manages to block it
elena shows up along with maya and she
ends up turning on her surrogate brother
the pair end up sparring with one
another and this of course calls back to
when they learned karate together as
kids on the ice elena says she needs to
know what happened with her sister and
though clint doesn't go into the ins and
outs of it yet he says that she
sacrificed herself elena doesn't buy it
and elsewhere kingpin confronts eleanor
kate arrives and shoots him with an
arrow which doesn't work and as we
learned in daredevil he wore armor under
his clothing and in his suit he had to
pull a few strings to get it and that's
an archery pun right there now eleanor
ends up hitting him with a car and back
at the rockefeller center echo and
causey continue their fight she ends up
stabbing him with one of the arrows and
potentially if kingpin comes back he
could end up blaming this on k or clint
cause he could also still be alive as we
don't really see him die and there is
potential that he could pop up as a
villain in the echo solo series now
realizing that kingpin is coming for her
she decides to tackle things head-on and
he watches kate fights him across town
mirroring this eleanor and klim battle
it out with one another and he tries to
tell her the truth but she does the old
you know the one stop lying it's a bit
cliched especially the stop-lying line
but florence pew acts brilliantly
delivering a grief-filled fight full of
rage and anger that does make it more
impactful just as she's about to kill
clint he busts out the whistle that
elena and her sister did his children
which makes her realize that he's
telling the truth elena of course
actually viewed the sleeper cell family
as a real one and she wanted nothing
more than them to be together nat was
very much a real sister to her and
hearing that she talked about her all
the time makes her realize how much she
meant in that and also how much clint
meant to her he talks about how they
escaped at the start of the movie namely
not flying the plane which is how they
got away after molina was shot elena
says she could have stopped her but we
know how stubborn that that was and that
it was her choice elena and clint let
bygones be by guns and thank god there
were no police there to just shoot them
from afar now against kingpin kate ends
up taking one of his cufflinks which has
the same design as it did in a netflix
show these belong to his father and
after he killed him he ended up wearing
them as a reminder we did say that we
thought the tone cost sorry coin toss
trick would be used to take out cozy but
i actually prefer that it returned here
she uses it to trigger the arrows which
all whack the big guy at the same time
anyone else in this position would have
been brown bred from this but guess we
need echo to have her big moment outside
elena tries to downplay what she's done
and she says that she did it for kate
she's clearly not morally right and kate
has no issues with seeing her arrested
on christmas as it's the right thing to
do now speaking of parental breakups we
see that kingpin escapes but that he's
confronted by ekko who arrives and
points a gun in his face just before
shooting him this actually pulls
directly from the comics and the
standoff is extremely similar now though
it seems like he died kingpin actually
survived in the comics though he was
blinded this was done to of course
mirror matt murdock and though there is
potential that he's dead i think it
would be a shame if marvel brought him
and matt murdock back just to kill off
the big guy in his first major
appearance i do believe that he will
survive and that maya will learn of this
down the line which we'll talk about
later on now clint congratulates kate
for taking down the kingpin and they
decide to walk the dog before we jump to
the barton farm to watch the family
meeting kate and spending christmas
together at this point we get
confirmation of one of our theories
which is that the watch belonged to
laura and on the back of it we can see
the logo for shield with the number 19
confirming that she was also an agent
now in case you don't know in the comics
clint was actually married to another
hero called mockingbird mockingbird or
rather barbara morse was a shield agent
drafted under the code name agent 19
which this of course confirms though we
don't know much about laura in the mcu
when the avengers first went to clint's
house in the age of ultron tony did
jokingly say that he thought she was an
agent potentially linking him with this
due to her constantly mocking her
enemies in fights she eventually took on
the card named mockingbird but she ended
up faking her death in order to return
to being a civilian interestingly
barbara also changed her name and thus
it could be connected because it's all
always connected i keep telling you you
don't listen
now outside clint burns their own
uniform along with kate and she tries to
brainstorm some nicknames in the comics
they constantly made jokes about how the
pair shared the same name because they
couldn't think of a better one and clint
says he has an idea for a name which is
when we cut her the title sequence just
before that though we can see the target
that was pinned up at the beginning of
avengers end game and it's an awesome
way to close out the series it's not
over yet though and in the post-credits
scene we see the rogers musical play out
adverts for this musical recently
appeared in spider-man noway home and
it's a nice way to close out the entry
as marvel wishes you a merry christmas
now we're gonna be talking about the
future direction of the mcu in just a
bit but as for my thoughts on the
episode and series as a whole i have
quite enjoyed it though i was a bit mad
on the first two episodes i thought
episode 3 was one of the best disney
plus shows ever made and from that point
on the series has set a high ball in
terms of ranking it amongst the other
shows i'm not sure exactly where i would
put it just yet but loki has definitely
remained as my favorite though the
ending of one division wasn't all that i
actually really enjoyed the journey and
all the speculation fan theories and
deeply laid easter eggs that made that
show something that i look back on
fondly even though everything didn't
completely pay off i'd put hawkeye in a
close third and i think that though i
probably have fonder memories of one
division that if we look at things
objectively that it's probably a better
show than one division is i just just
have so many happy memories of
constantly getting things wrong now
lastly is falcon and the winter soldier
but i also think that's a great show as
well sam bucky zemo and john walker all
get really good arcs in it and it is a
very solid they all are really but i
know you guys often ask me how i'd place
them so yeah that's where they drank for
me now go and kick off in the comments
here because i said hawkeye was
objectively better than one division but
i preferred that for the journey i know
you're gonna be angry at that because i
know what you're like you're a sucker i
love you though now going forward the
mcu has several things coming up that
will probably connect to this and we
will likely be getting the announcement
of a young avengers very soon almost all
of the pieces are in place now and with
ms marvel right around the corner and
america's chavez due to debut and doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness i
don't think it'll be too long before we
get an announcement on it whether that
will be a movie or a disney plus show we
don't know but i think come the end of
2022 we will know what's happening with
the team the most direct sequel to this
show though will probably be echo which
was announced on disney plus day ekko
has been one of the most interesting
characters in the entire series and
she's went on somewhat of an arc
changing from a villain to an anti-hero
she's one of the more complicated
characters in the marvel universe and
there's a lot of things that they can do
in her solo show she pretty much had to
get revenge for her father's death and
this has driven all of her actions
throughout her entire life now as i
mentioned earlier i do think that
kingpin will survive and that he'll be
back either having been blinded or
simply having just survived the bullet
in the comics after ekko discovered that
kingpin was the one responsible for her
father's death she ended up going head
to head with him but they've already
sort of done that daredevil was also
brought into the mix as well and
originally her father's death was pinned
on him and not the ronin this kind of
sparked up a rivalry between them and
potentially we could see her going
head-to-head with the devil of hell's
kitchen instead of the kingpin also
marvel yeah just give us more elena
below but please florence pew is
absolutely killing the role right now i
think that right there is some perfect
casting our next mcu entry is supposedly
going to be moonlight but as ms marvel
was supposed to debut in november this
year it could end up being that it's
gonna be interesting to see how that
turns out as such a big delay means that
they might have went and changed things
but we will see when that releases
anyway that wraps up the episode and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it make sure you drop them in the
comment section below and i hope that
you've enjoyed all the coverage over the
last five weeks i also hope that you
have a good christmas and thanks so much
for all the support over the last year
hopefully we'll hit the million
subscriber mark in 2022 and i couldn't
have done it without you so i really
appreciate all the love now as a thank
you we're running a competition right
now and giving away three copies of the
spider-man 4k trilogies on the 30th of
december all you have to do to begin
with the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
breakdown of why spiderman now at home
has the perfect ending i'm still
thinking about it now i'm getting
goosebumps it's absolutely incredible
and i'd love to see you over there right
after this if not then thanks for
sitting through the video i've been paul
you've been the best i'll see in the
next one take care merry christmas you
filthy animals and a happy new year much
love